The techniques and behavior patterns
of intruders are constantly shifting
in order to exploit newly discovered
weaknesses, and to evade detection and
counter measures.
However, intruders typically use steps
from a common attack methodology.
Here are the common attack steps.
The first step is target acquisition and
information gathering.
That is, the attacker identifies
the target systems using publicly
available information,
both technical and non-technical and
use network tools to
analyze target resources.
For example, the attackers can
find out what network services
are accessible from the Internet.
And the attacker may find
out some email accounts
of high level company executives.
The second step is initial access.
This is accomplished by exploiting
a remote network vulnerability.
For example, a network service has
a buffer overflow vulnerability that
allows a remote attack to take over
the service and gain access to a system.
Or this can be accomplished by social
engineering, whereby, for example,
an attacker can send an email to a
company executive with an attachment so
that when the attachment is clicked,
a malware is installed on the system.
The third step is privilege escalation.
This is taken after the initial access.
And the attacker would try to use local
exploit to escalate the privilege from,
for example, the normal user to root
privilege on the target system.
The fourth step is information
gathering or system exploit.
That is, after an attacker has gained
sufficient privilege on a system,
he can then find out more about
the network and the organization.
And even move to another target system
to further the exploit on the network.
The fifth step is maintaining access.
This is important because an attack
may not be a one-time action.
That is, the attacker may choose
to come back from time to time, or
continue the exploit for awhile.
Therefore, the attacker may install
backdoors or other malicious software on
a target system so that he can
continue to access this target system.
Lastly, the attacked wants
to cover his tracks.
For example, the attacker can disable or
even edit the system audit logs to
remove evidence of attack activities.
Or the attacker may install root
kits to hide the installed malware.